so between candace jody and the olson
twins which are the kids you get along
with best
whoever i was with at the moment just
like my own kids
i'm cl very close with candace always
was since we did the pilot
jody used to sleep over my house and
play with my daughter
aubry my oldest ashley and mary kate
i love so much and when i'm in new york
or when they're here when we can we see
each other
so i can't there's no favorite it's just
like picking your own kid favorite but
they're all friends
it's not like they're kids right but
jody was probably more like a kid to me
than ashley mary kate are more like
friends because i kind of got the whole
thing of
everything they're about and candace is
a friend
and she they've all been there for me
there was a
they've been all been there for me in a
big way when i've gone through hard
stuff
that's beautiful